olga avait cru que c'était un refuge et
pour un moment c'est bien ce qu'a été le
théâtre de mario paul où elle a conduit
son copain sa mère et sa grand-mère avec
médicaux que brothers
il y avait des soins médicaux il y avait
des médecins des gens faisait à manger
et
pose de community of hip hop c'était une
communauté et tout le monde attendait
pour ces corridors humanitaires
c'est la promesse d'une évacuation de
masse entendu à la radio qui a poussé
olga a quitté son appartement qui
avaient été endommagés dans une frappe
de l'armée russe c'était le 4 mars les
heures d'attentes se sont transformés en
jour et les jours sont devenus des
semaines que nos progrès pause
je n'arrive pas oubliés avec ma mère on
discute et on se dit que personne ne
peut nous comprendre parce que tous les
jours c'était un désastre c'était le
pire jour de notre vie mais pendant
trois semaines audoises freaks c'est
depuis la sécurité relative des apories
jacques olga acceptent d'offrir à visage
couvert par crainte de représailles
l'un des rares témoignages des
survivants de la frappe du théâtre de
marie au paul les autorités locales ont
avancé un bilan provisoire de 300 morts
olga est convaincu qu'il y en a
largement plus jusqu'à 1000 elle insiste
il n'y avait aucun militaire ukrainien
dans le théâtre bioniche ne suis dit ils
peuvent j'ai vu de mes propres yeux que
personne ne nous gardait il n'y avait
pas d'armes il n'y avait rien nous
vivions en communauté ils m'ont même
donné un travail au début je travaillais
dans le dépôt je distribuais des
vêtements pour les enfants après
j'écoutais la radio tout le monde
espérait un corridor d'évacuation sur
ces images aériennes prises avant le
bombardement on voit aussi clairement le
mode yéti enfants en russe écrit au sol
devant et derrière l'édifice tous les
jours le gars se demande si le choix de
rester à attendre une évacuation par les
autorités est le bon elle reste accroché
à la radio dans l'espoir ni entendre des
informations concrètes mais à la place
ce sont les rumeurs
voiture tombée en panne et de corps
déchiquetés sur les routes minées qui la
paralyse sur place les conditions de vie
sont abjects
pouvez vous imaginer trois semaines sans
se laver les cheveux sans se laver le
corps le visage vous ne vous brossez pas
les dents pouvez vous imaginer vivre
comme ça vous vivez dans un trou au sol
sans électricité peuvent regretter les
enfants ils étaient près de 510 tolga
pleurent sans arrêt et tout le monde
tombe malade fièvres diarrhées
vomissements mais autour d'elle tous les
jours il ya plus de monde sur tous les
étages du théâtre bolchoï
on est fort 6 des frères
l'abri anti bombe était pour 65
personnes et ne pouvait en accueillir
plus être aux yeux
c'était une petite pièce il était conçu
pour 50 personnes mais bon en poussant
65 personnes y étaient ce cabinet comme
tout comme l'union après les gens
étaient au sous-sol vivait dans un trou
éparpillés il y avait des bureaux sur
les trois étages c'était bondé il vivait
comme ça au sol partout
le 16 mars dernier quand le théâtre a
été frappé olga était enfermé dans un
petit bureau pour écouter les
informations à la radio
ce n'était pas une bombe aérienne
autrement on peut entendre les avions on
sent les vibrations qui font trembler
les fenêtres et on peut comprendre qu'il
faut bouger et se mettre à l'abri pour
sauver sa vie mais il y avait un silence
total
il existe très peu d'image des instants
qui ont suivi l'explosion olga
miraculeusement indemne a réussi à
pousser la porte de son bureau pour
aller sauver sa mère et sa grand-mère
gospel - babouche coup et ce projet en
écriture j'ai sauvé ma mère et ma
grand-mère quand le feu a commencé on
entendait des cris partout les gens
étaient en morceaux des bras arraché ici
des jambes là partout personne n'est
venu nous aider personne n'a été alain
sont dit je restais seul je suis tombé
dans la rue en criant à l'aide ma mère
m'a dit tu moi je ne veux plus vivre je
ne veux plus rien parce qu'elle ne
pouvait pas vivre avec de telles
blessures ma grand mère elle a 86 ans
elle a déjà survécu à la guerre et
maintenant une seule chose elle croit
que son copain est mort
il ya deux mois après l'explosion il est
resté sous les décombres je voudrais
vraiment retrouvé le téléphone des
volontaires qui peuvent au moins aller
dans les hôpitaux mais quand j'appelle
la ligne est coupée olga dû supplier des
voitures qui passaient pour conduire sa
mère à l'hôpital alors que les tirs
pleuvait tout près sa mère a reçu des
antidouleurs sans plus alors que les
médecins contempler l'amputation puis le
lendemain les soldats russes sont
débarqués une dune
un soldat russe est arrivé il a
dégoupillé une grenade en disant que si
on ne leur étaient pas il ferait sauter
tout le monde j'avais terriblement peur
et puis deschamps sont arrivés beaucoup
de soldats sont arrivés olga a réussi à
obtenir le transfert de sa mère dans un
autre hôpital avec la promesse de soins
plus adapté
nous sommes arrivés à l'hôpital il y
avait 300 soldats russes et nous avons
été fait prisonnier il y avait la fin
des gens mouraient de faim il ne donnait
que 50 grammes d'eau par personne tout
le monde voyait tout le monde est
l'infection s'est répandu sur trois
étages finalement olga a pu soudoyer su
qui les retenaient captive elle et sa
famille et appelé des amis à l'aide pour
transporter sa mère mais faute de place
dans la voiture sa grand mère elle a été
laissée derrière
olga est aujourd'hui rangé par des
questions qui restent sans réponse
tous les soirs nous faisions ne plièrent
parce qu'on pensait que dieu allait nous
sauver mais personne n'est venu nous
sauver je ne sais pas pourquoi et je
pense que je vais mourir avec cette
question pourquoi
elle en veut à son gouvernement de les
avoir laissés pour compte elle en veut
au reste du monde de ne pas avoir agi
pour les sauver à vladimir poutine elle
réserve tout ça n o ku
je le tuerais si j'avais la chance parce
que c'est un monstre ce n'est pas une
personne dûment or on ne sait pas
comment un homme avec des problèmes dans
sa tête peut contrôler un pays je sais
pas comment la communauté internationale
peut regarder en silence ou que vous
êtes un peu people le plus difficile dit
la jeune femme sait qu'elle n'arrive pas
non plus à se pardonner elle même
je me sens complètement vide je pense
que je n'ai plus d'âme je prends des
médicaments parce que les médecins
disent que j'ai besoin des deux je suis
une survivante et je me plante tous les
jours parce que c'est moi qui ai mené ma
famille au théâtre je me blâme à chaque
instant
un bruit me sur le revenu mais olga a
l'impression que ce n'est pas elle qui
est assise dans cet hôpital pour
raconter pour témoigner de ce qui s'est
passé tout ce qu'elle était avant la
guerre a été anéanti la positive la
patriote et la bienveillante olga est
morte elle aussi à mario paul